What has the actress who played Angela on
The Office been doing in the years since Dundler
Mifflin shut its doors?
As it turns out, she's been keeping pretty
busy, even if we don't see her every week
anymore.
Here's what Angela Kinsey is up to now.
In 2014, Kinsey jumped on board the Hulu sitcom
The Hotwives of Orlando, a merciless parody
of the Real Housewives franchise.
She starred alongside a bunch of other funny
ladies including Andrea Savage, Kristen Schaal,
and Casey Wilson.
In Season 1, Kinsey played Crystal Simmons,
an Orlando weather girl who considers herself
a devout Christian but has never read the
Bible because it's, quote, "written in Jewish."
In season 2, almost all the returning cast
members assumed new roles as the Hotwives
series headed to Las Vegas.
Kinsey's new character was Stephanie, an uptight
snob who created a rather unique food line.
"I developed a food line called 'Anorexi-Yeah!'
You know, I just wanted to take that word
back."
Starting in 2016, Kinsey starred in the Netflix
sitcom Haters Back Off as Bethany, mother
of the clueless and talentless Miranda Sings.
The show was an experiment in transforming
a YouTube sensation into a scripted TV show.
Miranda Sings was the creation of Colleen
Ballinger, whose millions of online followers
had already gotten to know the arrogant and
hopeless Sings long before she made the jump
to Netflix.
Ultimately, the experiment didn't last.
After two seasons, 16 episodes, and mixed
reviews, Haters Back Off was canceled.
But while critics may not have fallen in love
with the show as a whole, many singled out
Kinsey's performance as a reason to tune in.
Robert Lloyd of the Los Angeles Times said,
"[Kinsey] takes the series from a twisted
lark to something deeper and grander."
"This is my casual brace, okay?
I need my seductive one."
In August 2016, Kinsey announced on Instagram
her engagement to her boyfriend Joshua Snyder.
The proposal was quite adorable.
Kinsey's then 8-year-old daughter Isabel told
her she wanted to show Kinsey the fort she
and Snyder's sons had made outside.
But instead of a fort, a blanket was waiting
by their pool.
The boys brought her flowers and Snyder brought
her an engagement ring.
It was an emerald, the birthstone of all three
of their kids.
The happy couple got married that November
in Topanga, California.
Guests were given custom copper mugs, and
the wedding cake included a Lego cake topper
created by their children.
Fans of The Office will either be disappointed
or relieved to learn that there were no reports
of butter cow sculptures.
"I would like a cow butter sculpture of a
cat."
"That doesn't make any sense."
Angela Martin's love of cats was inspired
by Angela Kinsey's own love for the animals.
She regularly posts pictures of her own kitties
to her Instagram account, and her generosity
goes beyond showing how cute her cats are,
as she's a dedicated supporter of organizations
devoted to helping cats.
In 2014, Kinsey told the blog I Have Cat that
her work with charitable cat organizations
started with what she was doing with her own
free time.
An old neighborhood of hers was crawling with
stray cats, and she would get them spayed
and neutered before releasing them back into
the neighborhood.
She also discussed how she brought her love
for cats into her performance on The Office.
While shooting the pilot episode, she improvised
a line where she invited everyone to a cat
birthday party and went so far as to pass
out post-it note invites to her castmates.
In December 2016, Kinsey and her husband Josh
Snyder launched the webseries Baking With
Josh & Ange on YouTube.
The show was apparently Colleen Ballinger's
idea, who suggested it when Snyder brought
some cookies while visiting Kinsey on the
Haters Back Off set.
Though initially intimidated by the idea of
having to deal with the necessary technology
required for a webseries, Kinsey and Snyder
gave it a go and they seem to be doing pretty
well.
They've even had a guest appearance from Kinsey's
former TV husband, as Rainn Wilson stopped
by to make vegan brownies.
He'd only recently started eating vegan, and
judging by his facial expressions, the brownie
experiment may not have been a phenomenal
success.
"This is really good.
You would never know it's vegan."
Apparently, you can buy clothes from vending
machines now.
You may not have known that, but Angela Kinsey
does.
In March 2018, she posted a video and multiple
shots of herself on her Instagram account,
announcing that she had bought a jacket from
an airport vending machine.
Kinsey's followers and fans were so tickled
by this development that someone actually
created an Instagram account just for the
jacket.
It has close to 30,000 followers, including,
of course, Kinsey herself.
So if you're ever feeling like you need a
little humiliation, just remember, unless
you're super-popular on Instagram, there are
at least 30,000 people in the world who like
a jacket more than they like you.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.